because i watched an episode and
you know
talk to me about it talk to me how
briefly how it got started with with you
and reza aslan and how these two minds
came to be and and and to make this show
that and a show that you both wanted to
make because i think it's it's very
important ultimately it's like
what is our life why are we here what's
the purpose what's like all answering
all these questions and you can't really
answer all them i guess the best of your
ability but why did you do this
um
so
i started about 11 or 12 years ago a
media company called soul pancake that
was a digital media company it existed
mostly most people know it as a very
successful youtube channel with three or
four million subscribers we had shows
like kid president uh my last days
the science of happiness lots of that
were viral videos that people posted all
over facebook and whatnot so my first
iteration of that was called
metaphysical milkshake that's what i
originally wanted to call it because
i've just always been interested in the
metaphysical questions about being a
human being and being alive why are we
here
what happens when we die what is what is
our purpose but beyond that like what is
time and uh you know do we have free
will and you know so many metaphysical
questions that intersect with psychology
spirituality philosophy
creativity on a lot of different fronts
sociology
and
so soul pancake went in its direction it
did its thing i had a show on soul
pancake for a short amount of time
called metaphysical milkshake where i
interviewed people the bus in the back
of my van yeah in the back of your head
and um that was what i talked about that
was fun because i always liked the name
and then i knew reza aslan's work and we
had bumped into each other at a couple
events and we were having breakfast
actually not far from here uh in the
hollywood hills and um
you know we were just talking about life
and
we're like god this our conversation
should just be a podcast and him and i
really have the similar um interests in
terms of the topics that we want to
discuss
and that started the process of us you
know starting this podcast um
life's big questions what it means to be
a human being you know because i i feel
like our our country is so divided
people are at each other's throats
there's so much there's this mental
health epidemic with young people going
on
that is uh
really
it's tragic it's horrible
the anxiety depression suicidal ideation
you read the statistics around
kids you know it used to be the
statistic that always has blown my mind
the most is um
uh all since they since they since the
they started doing any kind of studies
at all about psychology the loneliest
generation was always senior citizens
because a lot of they're in old folks
homes and whatnot or they're put out to
pasture whether they're living alone or
whatever that was always the loneliest
generation this shifted about eight
years ago the loneliest generation
became
high school and college kids the
loneliest generation guess what that
synced up
with smartphones
and instagram and social media there's
other factors but those are those are
two really big disconnect it is a
disconnect they're not they are feeling
seemingly connected because you have
instagram oh look someone liked me i
have 287 instagram friends it's like
they're not your friends how many of
them are really your friends four three
zero you know zero